new DNA evidence could impact the future
of an inmate who has been on death row
for more than 35 years
Kevin Cooper was convicted of the 1983
chino hills' massacre in california that
left four people dead and an
eight-year-old boy critically injured
Cooper has always maintained his
innocence now the case is getting
international attention from big names
like Kim kardashian-west and the Pope
last month then California Governor
Jerry Brown ordered new DNA tests on
four pieces of evidence from the case
Erin Moriarty has been reporting on this
case for nearly 20 years and shares new
details in this week's 48 hours nearly
20 years ago I got a stack of letters
from an inmate at San Quentin prison he
wrote that he was innocent and had been
framed Cooper had been convicted of the
murders of Doug and Peggy Ryan their
daughter Jessica and neighbor
Christopher Hughes inside the Ryan home
in Chino Hills California
in June of 1983 eight and a half year
old Josh Ryan barely survived what does
something like this do to a person's
life changes their life and you lose
somebody in it it hurts there was strong
evidence pointing to multiple assailants
at the hospital Josh indicated three
people were involved three weapons were
used and blood inside the Ryan's stolen
car was found on three seats but then
investigators discovered that one
escaped prisoner Kevin Cooper a career
burglar had been hiding out in a vacant
house near the Ryan's home defense
attorney Norman Heil when you have such
a gruesome crime in a neighborhood like
that finding somebody to pin it on was
very important and Kevin Cooper was a
convenient person to pin it on the
problem was they didn't have the
evidence there were no fingerprints or
any of Cooper's hair in the house the
state
that only one tiny drop of blood scraped
off a wall match Cooper's blood type
hi-oh believes authorities planted that
blood they planted his blood in order to
keep him in prison but I'd like to prove
that he's innocent
hile also believes evidence was
deliberately destroyed like bloody
coveralls turned into investigators by
Diana Roper and I picked him up that I
saw the blood in mm Roper told me that
her ex-boyfriend paroled killer Li
furrow was wearing them the night of the
murders did you kill the Ryan family no
I did not or Christopher Hughes
no I did not I had nothing to do with
any of this em former District Attorney
Michael Ramos agrees he was 30-plus
miles away from the crime scene when
this murder occurred
was it Li furrow Kevin Cooper or someone
else new DNA tests may provide answers
Erin Moriarty is with us now this case
is how many years old 30 well 35 and
we've been on it for a long time because
there's a man's life at stake yeah
Kevin Cooper came within four hours of
being executed in 2004 so I think it's
really important to find out whether
there's an ascender killer why the new
DNA test now well I think in short it's
because of social media last May
christophe nicholas kristof from the new
york times wrote an op-ed it got picked
up a lot of places and of all people Kim
kardashian-west
started tweeting about it and there was
and the Pope got involved there was so
much pressure on the governor that on
Christmas Eve he decided to order not
all the tests that could have been done
but four of the tests it's not the first
time a request has been made to the
governor but what do you think Erin
about this case you've been on it for 20
years do you think he's innocent well
big question is whether that the small
amount of evidence that points um was
tampered with and more important three
different weapons how does one man these
people all had injuries from three
different weapons how does one man do it
put one down is he picks up another it
never made sense to me there's blood in
the three
of the the getaway car no there are a
lot of questions about this case which
is why we stuck with it Aaron thank you
so much and you can watch was Kevin
Cooper framed in a special two-hour
episode of 48 hours that's tomorrow at
9:00 8:00 central right here on CBS